Thirty years ago in 1917,
the Russian revolution defeated the
Russian empire after more than three
centuries of czarist rule,
the Romanovs were replaced in a violence
wave,
other Soviet regime,
the seed that would turn into the
Soviet,
but the results of this wasn't exactly
more freedom for the Russian people.
How are the.
This is not a history video.
We're not going to discuss the past,
but rather the present and that's
because many are seeing the new
situation in Russia as the rebirth of a
new cyrus regime.
But is it fair to really talk about a
new czarist?
Russia isn't perhaps some kind of
overreaction.
Well,
let's see.
By the way,
in this video you're also going to learn
what is the fastest way to become rich,
filthy rich and facts,
but don't worry,
we haven't gotten insane and we're not
going to try and tell you about a great
opportunity you're missing out on with
pyramid scheme xY,
,
Z.
I'll explain more in a bit.
Around 18 years ago,
on the 30,
first of December,
1999 are still unknown.
Vladimir Putin became the president of
Russia and in 2018,
Putin will likely win the elections and
remained presidents for another six
years,
so when this next legislative term is
finished in 20,
24,
cute in that will have already ruled
Russia for 25 years and this is a longer
period of role than many of the songs
from Russia's pre-revolution history.
Indeed,
Putin has developed a political system
with a close resemblance to that of the
older Russian empire.
Boozing has developed a similar
political system,
but with a personal touch and just a
dusting of Soviet seasoning.
On the one hand,
Putin's new regime has restored two of
the main features of the older ussr,
propaganda and repression.
Opposition leader Alexei Navalny,
jailed as 1,750 arrested during protests
across Russia.
That's right.
With Putin and charge,
we could say that the secret service and
the political police,
which once was the old kgb,
I've come back to life and they are now
known as the Federal Security Service.
Also,
one of the first things boot in did when
he reached was to take control over
television and the media and set up a
powerful campaign of patriotic
glorification with a clear goal.
That goal being to get people to
subscribe to the notion that,
Hey,
bruce and Sarah and Russia's amazing
again,
all right,
but if we consider the use of propaganda
rindge,
repression of Soviet heritage,
mostly,
why are we talking about a new saw?
Well,
that's partly because he has restored
the close alliance between the Orthodox
Church and the state,
but mainly because Putin has
consolidated a state controlled by a
powerful oligarchy that is similar to
the old feudal system or the aristocracy
of the Russian empire.
You See,
Putin has befriended a group of people
to whom he has granted control of the
big companies in the country and whom he
has made very rich.
I remember when I told you we were going
to tell you the fastest way to become a
multimillionaire.
Well,
this is the formula,
the friend Vladimir Putin,
so believe me,
I'll consider this.
We can talk about Sergei roles again.
Putin's childhood friends.
He received around $2,000,000,000 in
government funds or other close friends
like ego section,
Putin's old chief of staff or Alexi
Miller and all his collaborator and
consultants,
or there's Sergei tremor,
resolve and old friends from the KGB.
They are all multimillionaires today and
they are the ceos of some of the most
important state owned companies.
Gazprom and and Ross tack no bad.
Right,
and do you think for a moment,
these are isolated situations.
There are tons of examples.
Tymchenko,
Rosenberg,
truck Shama love.
It can be definitely said that if you
are friends you aren't doing or right
indeed.
Many of these people appear in the
Forbes list of the wealthiest people in
the world and it is not just them.
I mean these people,
they're now getting old and they are
passing on that wealth to their
children.
It is normal to see many of these big
national companies that have grown
enormously since Putin reached power
being run by the 25 to 35 year old
children of Putin's friends.
Degas Lucas,
Nikolai Shama law,
a multimillionaire,
friends of Poussin,
aunties to children.
One of them year.
He became the CEO of gas phones,
one of the most important retirement
funds in Russia.
The other Kirill,
he was the vice president of sperm.
They large state controls petrochemical
company when he was just 25 years old.
By the way,
Carol Marriott's Putin's daughter soon
after,
and you know what?
He's an LV,
wealthiest young person in Russia with a
fortune exceeding $1,000,000,000.
Indeed the prime minister Dmitry
Medvedev hasn't been accused of getting
rich from the state and having palaces
and vineyards all over Russia.
I'm actually going to link to a
documentary that exposed all of this in
the description below.
It is absolutely worth or watch,
and so now you might be wondering why is
Putin doing all of this is just a really
generous dues.
Well,
whether he is or not,
that is not.
His real goal here is not just making
his friends rich because they are his
friends.
Well Putin is trying to do with this
strategy is grant himself control over
the resources of the state as well.
Who's paying for this?
Well,
that would be these citizens of Russia.
All right,
so we have oligarchy,
repression,
religion,
propaganda for state control,
control over all economic and political
issues in Russian society and these
makeup,
the main ingredients of the political
regime created by this and use,
and it goes beyond Zanny ideological
reproach.
Look at what [inaudible] Jones,
a famous leftwing British person had to
say,
right wing authoritarian leader who
attacks civil liberties,
stigmatizes,
lesbian,
gay,
bisexual,
and transgender people indulgence and
chauvinism,
nationalism.
He's in bed with rapacious oligarchs and
who is admired by the European and
American heart,
right?
Russia is ruled by a human rights
abusing expansionist,
oligarchic regimes,
the Russian people and their deserve
better.
Owen Jones.
And while now you might be wondering.
Yeah,
but what about outside of Russia?
I mean,
how much power does Vladimir Putin and
command on the world stage?
Well,
as we already said in a previous video
about China,
we can understand power as influence and
we can observe three brunches,
military,
economic and political.
Yeah.
Rebirth of a Titan,
Vladimir Putin,
Russia into one of the countries with
the highest relative spend on the
military,
way above China and the USA.
Just take a look at this chart while the
US is spending approximately nine
percent of the government's budget and
China is spending around six percent.
Russia is spending more than 15 percent
of the budget supporting the army right
after the fall of the Soviet Union in 19
nineties,
the image of Russian forces was a rusty
boats,
planes that could fly and corrupt
officials that you'd like to empty their
arsenals to sell the weapons on the
black market who's in?
Well,
he wants it to change that and today
things they are very,
very different.
Since Putin reached power and especially
since 2008,
Putin has made it a priority to update
to the army.
So in the last few years they have spent
tens of billions of dollars turning the
old Russian army into a modern military
force.
But even more important than that is
that they have made serious upgrades to
that fire firepower plains missiles,
ships.
They are all being updated.
Look closely in 2015 alone,
according to the figures of the Russian
Ministry of Defense,
the army got four ships for submarines
50 to support ships,
27 aircrafts and 45 artillery units,
but not everyone shares this opinion.
In fact,
one former US general told me that a
single US super aircraft carrier group
could obliterate the entire Russian navy
as the equipment is so dated and
technologically obsolete.
Azeem O'brian research professor at the
United States Army War College.
Regardless,
we could save the Russian army has
become a key part of Moscow's
international politics,
and it is not just this political
influence in other countries and
international conflicts,
but also the renewed capacity of the
Russian arms industry.
Further,
do not forget about all those nukes they
have.
They have a lot of nukes,
feet
of clay.
Now,
if we can see the Russian army as an
asset for Pearson,
the wrecked Russian economy is certainly
his main weakness.
Russia is basically a producer and an
exporter of natural resources and
Russia's economy isn't nowhere even
close to China's.
In the last few decades,
Russia has been unable to diversify or
develop a complex and productive
economy,
not even close.
Russia is more and more dependent on its
natural resources every day.
Indeed,
they are so dependent on them that
everything is great.
When the prices are high,
that's when they are not a crisis kicks
off.
These are Barack Obama's words from his
final press conference.
As presidents,
the Russians can't change us or
significantly weaken us.
They're a smaller country.
They weaker country.
Their economy doesn't produce anything
that anybody wants to buy except oil and
gas and arms.
They don't innovate.
Barack Obama as the oligarchy states and
those Putin is creators has a lot to do
with it.
The state has simply taken a more and
more important role in the economy since
2005.
It was then 35 percent and today it is
70 percent and let us not forget that
this process has been led by Putin's
buddies and sure in this situation,
I mean,
of course corruption spreads and
competition disappears and with those
things gone.
There's not really much of an incentive
for them to do things right,
and that's why the future of Russia's
economy,
it's looking pretty bleak once some
proof of this,
but in 2016,
more than 400,000 people left the
country and many of these people,
whether young and educated anyway,
the Russian model,
it just doesn't seem capable of
encouraging growth and development in
the country and besides think about it,
this is a weakness itself.
A poor economy means less influence and
less potential to develop the military.
And finally the third branch,
and that's political power.
We could discuss further the moves with
China or the Russian strategy in the
Middle East where Moscow is trying to
take influence from their less than the
United States,
but I think we should leave that for a
future video.
So now we wonder,
what's your opinion?
What do you think about Vladimir Putin?
Do you agree with us?
Disagree?
Well,
leave your answers in the comments below
as well as in this survey,
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday and do not
forget to check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine,
and as always,
thank you for.
Okay.